nakatomi plaza that is from die hard and
that is a very good shirt i like that
you will like this then hold on it's
from the christmas party from 88. that's
spectacular wow
alan rick mr tagaghi will not be joining
us for the rest of his life
i remember a sophomore high school and
uh i'll never forget when i first saw
die hard
it was
amazing yeah the movie's a masterpiece
uh daniel when you get older and your
family allows you to watch it you should
really watch die hard so i'm curious
daniel i want to start with you um this
is obviously your first movie and i'm i
am very curious what actually surprised
you about making a movie that maybe you
weren't expecting going in
i was
not expecting how much goes into a movie
because you you film the movie and then
right after you have like 100 things and
while you're filming the movie they have
like
ah all these different little
little things in the background that
just makes the the movie great and i
just didn't realize how much goes into a
room together you do all these
interviews did you
i didn't realize this there you go
then when i was watching it uh there's a
scene where you're in the school and
you're talking to the psychologist
and i swear i was looking at chucky 25
years later from goodwill hunting um is
that sort of how you played that scene
or is it just my imagination
i i mean that's actually that's a very
observant uh
point that that is something that i i
described the role often to people as
if the chalky character from good
hunting uh i mean i assume we did grow
up he grew up what he would be might be
like and doing and um
it was definitely connected to that yeah
for sure and in fact there's a lot more
in common with the
the
the part of long island and part of
boston that story was said and then i
think maybe people might think and and
definitely those characters and it was
the same energy makes me sound like a
little bit of a one-trick pony but it's
actually true so what can i say
uh i am a big fan of william monahan and
his uh screenwriting ability um daniel i
don't think you've read too many
screenplays but i'm curious for both of
you could you sort of talk about what it
was about the the script and the
dialogue and what you were doing that
really appealed to you
and what you thought was really good
about it you read the screenplay right
did you read this script no you know
it's good
but uh what did you like about the story
though what do you like with the
characters
i like to they all got together as a
family because that's very important in
life you have to
have a great family and your family
members have to have your back and you
have to have their backs that's one of
the most important things that is a uh
stunningly accurate articulation of
exactly how i felt about the story too i
don't know that i could say it any
better um i'm being a very talky person
i will try but the the truth is what
he's saying is right it's uh it's about
family and the importance of love and
family and and the need to um
connect as human beings and to love and
care for and parent children whatever
that looks like whatever your family
model is has to be underpinned by love
and time and commitment and the sense
that kids get from adults in their lives
that they are worth something it means
something and can accomplish what they
want in life uh i think that's the
most important
aspect of raising children
obviously i'm a huge fan of george
clooney both in front of and behind the
camera um and i read that uh
ben that he gave you a note as a
performer that you had actually not
gotten before like a direction if you
will just curious daniel can you also
talk about working with george and maybe
some of the way he directed you that
maybe you know surprised you or helped
you become a better actor
um
first of all george was a great guy i'm
not just saying that like
he he was just a great guy and so was
ben
but you are just saying that no no okay
not because i'm next to you no no
and i really love them a lot and
um
george gave me some good advice when
on filming
you have to put like a little more
action into the films and sometimes if
it's like emotional you you could talk
low but if it's like action
talk like you're um
like you're
like i can't explain more energy yeah
like more energy
yeah guys ready to do die hard uh
the fourth whatever the next one gets
ready for the action movies
yes yeah george helped you a lot and one
of the things george did for both of us
i think was to make the set at least i
think so feel very comfortable like i
didn't feel like self-conscious like oh
people are gonna make fun of me right
made us feel very comfortable when we
were filming
i i read and i could be wrong about this
but daniel you are a big fan of batman
is that correct
yes
so i'm just i'm just curious on how many
days did it take for you to talk to ben
about batman was it the first day the
second day or the third day first day
they were they were rearranging the
camera and we were sitting next to each
other in the chairs and like i was like
so i was playing batman i mean we just
kept on talking just like that yeah
he's he does a batman fan
although if i was a youtuber that would
be the ultimate level
but you know
that
that's actually something i'm not where
i was going with this interview but my
sister's kids are obsessed with youtube
and youtube stars like my kids are too
that's that's what they mostly watch
yeah and so i'm curious daniel what is
it who are your favorite youtubers and
for ben what is it i mean isn't it weird
seeing or is it
i guess i'm just it's so it's just not
what i was brought up with so i'm so
not used to it you know what i mean
who's your favorite youtuber mr beast
right i i actually know mr beast and is
it because did you watch his squid game
thing
yeah i i sure i i also liked them a lot
before so to my son he was an early it
was a fan yeah before it became cool
yeah you know yeah it's interesting it's
like it's a a different form of like
communicating telling stories and doing
stuff and one that obviously is you know
i mean youtube is only it feels like a
relatively recent um
you know uh development you know i mean
it is certainly in the grand scheme of
things and so and then the the
the communication that evolved within
that technology what that allowed is
just something different than long form
longer form you have on the one hand the
internet um streaming allowed like the
more serial for like this extended like
mini series things you know to be
um like more in-depth examination of
characters and stories and on the other
hand there is this kind of also this
very interstitial shorter form thing and
i think what's happened is that with the
freedom for people to sort of create at
whatever length they they kind of want
to tell their story you found all kinds
of different stories and forms of
storytelling and and stuff that i didn't
it was hard for me to even um you know
that i was behind the curve and a lot of
stuff i've like learned from my kids and
what they watch and and i first got like
what is this and then as i watch i go
like this is really interesting there's
like something really interesting and
um happening in particular mr beast
great guy nice guy like your like his
stuff on youtube and um
it's it's it is uh it's not how i grew
up i i know it's not the entertainment
that i watched because it wasn't there
but it doesn't mean like i think there's
also tendency when you like get older to
be like these kids are all watching the
youtube you know what i mean that's a
fast road to dinosaur dumb i think
a hundred percent uh i got to stop there
i'm just going to leave it with ben i
really hope you're directing something
again soon i really like it when you're
behind the camera thank you so much
uh daniel congrats on your first movie
you did fantastic thank you